so if i can take one little detour here
yeah there's something i wanted to
introduce which um
a friend um pointed this out
in a conversation some weeks ago and it
has
stuck with me there is a scientific
result
that increasingly i think explains one
of the weirdest features
of this modern chaos
which is the tendency of the claims
to be most overblown in places where
they are least likely to be true
right so portland is the site of these
riots over anti-black racism
portland is as liberal as city as exists
in the country
presumably anti-black racism is less
prevalent here than it is
almost anywhere else why is it happening
same thing with evergreen
why was evergreen the site of this most
incredible
set of protests about uh white supremacy
of all places for white supremacy uh to
be difficult to find you would imagine
evergreen would be top of the list
and you know for me to be their first
target demonstrates just how difficult
it was to find
just how difficult it was to find so
anyway here's the question
uh zach could you put up the paper that
i sent you
so what this paper describes is an
experiment
that tested what people's perception
initially about
color having no connotation whatsoever
blue versus purple
people's perception of color as one
color in the experiment
became increasingly rare
so let me read the abstract to the
extent i can do that from here
do you want me yeah you want to do it i
can see it yeah why do some social
problems seem so intractable
in a series of experiments we show that
people often respond to decreases in the
prevalence of a stimulus by expanding
their concept of it
when blue dots became rare participants
began to see purple dots as blue
when threatening faces became rare
participants began to see neutral faces
as threatening
and when unethical requests became rare
participants began to see innocuous
requests as unethical
this prevalence-induced concept change
occurred even when participants were
forewarned about it
and even when they were instructed and
paid to resist it
social problems may seem intractable in
part because reductions in their
prevalence lead people to see more of
them
wow so this is again like like with the
noam chomsky
interview in the new yorker i've not
seen this before so i i've not read the
paper i can't say
what's in it or this is published you
said 2018 yeah
or maybe you said that to me off air um
so there's probably been time for
rebuttal if there has been time for a
battle and i don't know if there
has been i looked i did not i do not see
it a rebuttal
um amazing it's
amazing so if we can just put this in
context you and i immediately spot in
that abstract
um a claim that if true has
tremendous implications for things like
claims of injustice in effect what we've
got is
a kind of built-in apparently
neurological relativism
that as something becomes rare finds it
where it
isn't now you can imagine that there are
all kinds of reasons that your
neurobiology would have such a feature
right imagine
neurological relativism you're searching
for berries right
the berries you will find first are
going to be the ones that are obvious
and right in front of your face
as those get depleted because you've
picked all the good ones you have to
become
increasingly sensitive so diminishing
returns causes your perception
to need to get more sensitive you need
to effectively become
visually buried paranoid in order to
spot the one that's halfway hidden by
the leaf
i know yeah that's an incredible phrase
isn't it but visually very paranoid
visually very paranoid yes okay so you
can imagine that this could result in
you collecting more berries per
hour a kind of increase in your
sensitivity
the problem or it's you know you've hit
that point in the diminishing returns
curve where you should go
fish instead or go to a totally
different part of the right part of your
locality but imagine how that would play
out if you were looking for barriers
right right your sensitivity goes up
which means you keep finding the ones
that are harder and harder to find and
then eventually
you're seeing phantom berries where they
aren't you're just seeing a shadow or a
dark space in the thing and you're
reaching in and you're getting
nailed by a thorn right the point is
that will that calculation will hit you
too
and it'll be like i keep thinking i'm
gonna get something and there's no
reward i keep thinking i'm gonna get it
no reward no reward right but there's
physical feedback with regard to
visually buried paranoia
right and there's no there's not
inherently
any actual physical feedback when it's
claims that are entirely socially
constructed around
i am sure that he said that to me
because he's racist right
so what you've got as a system that has
i think an objective analysis would tell
you that there was a great deal of
racism at the founding of the country
even people who wanted to know better
still didn't right and that the degree
to which racism is a commonly
encountered phenomenon has dropped
dramatically and that at this point in
history
we are in objective terms far better off
than we were with respect to this thing
that we all agree is bad
however and not only that but better
than most of the world
better than most of the world and we all
know what the goal is which is
zero racism right so that's an amazing
degree of
progress but the point is what it
accompanies is a decrease
in actual examples of racism that you
encounter
which if this paper is right and general
which it
suggests it seems to be by virtue of the
fact that they weren't just looking at
colors they were looking at things like
perceptions of threat and perceptions of
injustice
that what this suggests is that as the
phenomenon in question becomes
increasingly rare
people will find it where it isn't yeah
which
raises rather directly the specter that
microaggressions and
every analog of them is going to be
formulated as you approach zero with
respect to this being a common
phenomenon
right and so what will that look like
well it will certainly in
a case where let's say there was zero
racism in policing and i'm not saying
that there is
but let's say that we reached zero right
there would still be
bad shootings and things because to have
people enforcing the law with guns
guarantees there will be a certain
number of bad shootings we'll hit
something close to zero racism and
policing
before we will hit zero errors in
violence in policing right
and then what you would predict is that
people will read into
events that actually weren't bad
shootings or events that were bad
shootings but were not racially biased
they will read into it exactly this
thing
and that of course could derange
civilization especially if you had an
online amplification mechanism
for these things so um you know think
about the term
white supremacy right white supremacy
was a thing that
everybody would have agreed was
vanishingly rare 15 years ago
because we all understood it to be
something pretty dramatic right it
wasn't just garden variety racism it was
an aggressive
belief structure that you know crosses
burning on lawns and this kind of thing
and gosh i want to say every but let's
just say
nearly every elected official in the
united states would have been proud to
get up and
say obviously i oppose white
supremacists obviously
obviously right it's the most obvious
thing in the world and now we're getting
to the point where
the absence of overt white supremacy
right the relegating of that ugly
terrible phenomenon to a tiny number of
people on the fringe that doesn't matter
right that thing is now being read into
all kinds of stuff right
structural racism and your failure to
say anything about it is the equivalent
of
white supremacy which is insane
right so i would argue um first of all
we need to take the terms back
white supremacy i would argue that there
is a floor a natural floor based on
the common parliament's interpretation
of the words
that a white supremacist should by
definition
at the very least have to be rooting for
white people
to rule over others they would have to
be rooting for white people to win
right and that means that it can't be a
feature of
a structure right it can't be a feature
if you
are somebody who doesn't want to see uh
one race win
over other races then that to me
suggests you can't be a white
supremacist it doesn't mean you can't be
uh ignorant it doesn't mean that you
can't be part of the problem
right you could be you could be ignoring
important patterns but
that term would seem to suggest an a
desire to see something
rather than just a an indifference to it
yeah
i mean there's there's a lot more to be
explored here one of
my concerns with what you just said
though is that there is
widespread conflation between
individuals and populations
right that that most people actually
don't understand when they have
jumped that giant gap between talking
about an individual versus talking about
a population
and um while that i find egregious and
really we should be educating people
much much better such that people
understand
the distinction between individual
population level analysis
and level of responsibility uh what is
less surprising to me
is that well maybe actually more
more surprising in some ways is uh that
scientists themselves contribute to this
to this confusion
and i i
i actually don't think i'm going to go
here now i think i i don't i don't
quite agree with you are saying we need
the terms back because i think
i have been interested in getting for
instance the term feminism back for a
long time and i sort of i sort of gave
up
you know i've been calling long before
we were ever on any sort of
national stage i was calling what has
been passing for feminism since the mid
90s faux feminism faux feminism
and you know with candy on the stage
taking so much you know
collecting so many resources and having
so much power
i just i just don't know if it's
possible to take these terms back and
the just and the distinction
i guess and this is what i was going to
say that um
you know can if an individual can be a
white supremacist
does it necessarily follow that an
organization cannot be
i don't think it necessarily follows but
i do think that
it is absolutely necessary to whenever
you're making that leap
from a category that applies to
individuals and you are now applying it
to
to structures to systems to populations
to organizations
to be clear that that is what you are
doing and that it therefore may not hold
this they therefore may be an
illegitimate move because evolutionary
processes don't
work on the same in the same way between
individuals and populations
well okay a couple things one let me
clarify
it's not uh obviously i don't want to
take the term white supremacy back i
don't want
it right what i want that's not what
you're saying right i want to corral
the term uh to a reasonable
standard and the important thing that we
are seeing i think
we are seeing it overtake quality
thought
across the board is a
demotion of intent
as relevant to the assessment of
a the presence of a thought pattern and
so you know for
for chomsky to say that trump is the
greatest criminal in human history
and for his explanation to be that he
doesn't care about intent the point is
the hazard
right this is garbage thinking
[Music]
you